il y en a t'il par mais vous qui
choisissez votre magasin d'épicerie en
fonction que la musique d'ambiance c'est
bon c'est bon savez vous que la musique
d'ambiance peut affecter nos
comportements en magasin par exemple et
nos décisions d'achat
par exemple une musique avait duré
plantes peuvent faire en sorte qu'on va
magasiner plus longtemps alors
l'équation est simple pour le commerçant
nous on passe plus de temps dans le
magasin ce qui veut dire on va prendre
m'en acheter plus ça peut aussi affecter
nos décisions aussi par exemple un vin
français on pense que c'est notre
décision de l'acheter mais s'il ya du
piaf ou du jean ferrat qui joue c'est
peut-être l'influencent de la musique
aussi
si on va au resto il ya des exemples
pour comme ça pour chacun des autres
quatre sens si on va au resto un resto
de gamme
ils vont nous servir des ustensiles
qu'on connaît le sens qu'ils sont lourds
ceci donne l'impression de qualité
on a emmené plus apprise on est prêt
excuse moi on est plus impressionné par
le plan qui est servi devant le même
chose pourra être fait avec le café un
café chaud dans nos mains quand on
rencontre quelqu'un ça va faire en sorte
qu'on a l'impression qu'ils aient plus
chaleureux que mettons aussi en levant
un verre d'eau aux olympiques
le couloir pour être aussi un gros
facteur pour ceux qui font des paris
sportifs horaires des tags les
statistiques mais n'oubliez pas de
regarder la couleur d'uniformes vous en
était que les boxeurs sont assignés
soins couleur rouge ou en couleur jaune
rouge bleu aléatoirement et en général à
cause de l'influencé sur l'agression que
le rouge ya le rouge sont plus portés à
gagner deux matches au football des fois
les on va penser des hocklines riders
comme une équipe méchant est ce que
c'est juste c'est à cause de leur
couleur
les équipes vêtu en noir recevront
recevoir resservent ont plus de
pénalités que des équipes habillé à
d'autres couleurs
un verre d'eau si on veut a été
influencé par le club ça affecte aussi
nos perceptions de goût un verre d'eau
par exemple on ajoute tout simplement un
peu de colorant jaune et on peut faire
en sorte à faire accroire à quelqu'un
qui s'étaient eux aussi trôné même si à
aucun goût citronné parlant de l' odeur
de citron
l'odeur de citron dans un sale va faire
en sorte qu'on va être peut-être plus on
va prendre le temps de prendre plus de
soin à le garder nettoyer alors tout ça
dans mon expérience en marketing dans le
domaine de marketing puis la recherche
marketing
j'ai toujours été fasciné par l'elysée
le pouvoir des sens ce que j'aime
appeler un autre chanceux riels
autrement dit un élément sensorielle
qu'il change notre façon d'agir qui sans
changer notre comportement
le premier contexte dans lequel j'ai
étudié les notes chance auriel c'était
de contexte de magasinage yann l'étude
qui avait sorti qui disait que en
moyenne que ce soit du fatigue mentale
ou physique on dure seulement 26 minutes
dans un dans un magasin ceci équivaut à
peu près au premier aller d'un iker
premier à lesdins costco ou peut-être
durant le temps des fêtes on va passer
26 minutes dans une file d'attenté alors
ça ça ça impacte aussi le reste de notre
vie si on est fatigué à faire des choses
que l'on peut juger être essentiel
qu'est ce qui arrive pour nos loisirs
qu'est ce qui arrive pour le temps qu'on
avec notre famille qu'on est fatigué
d'avoir fait l'épicerie c'est un peu
plate alors moi je vous laisse vous
voulez déterminer si une façon qu'on
pouvait augmenter l'endurance dans un
magasin même si c'est juste le
perception des consommateurs
alors avec mon expérience comment
appeler être d'environ j'ai pensé
comment qu'on faisait de façon légale
pour être plus endurants dans les sports
comme la course
la natation ou le vélo puis une image
qui me restait en tête c'est des
cyclistes qui mettait des boules de
coton dans le nez avant une course
ces boules de coton était un but et de
l'huile de menthe poivrée puis l'image
est drôle l'idée est drôle mais c'est
basé sur une vraie recherche y ont
trouvé que l'odeur demande pourrait
pouvait augmenter notre endurance sur
des tâches comme des redressements assis
ou des prochains alors moi je voulais
savoir est ce que c'est possible
d'appliquer sa dans un magasin le
problème était le gros problème était
trouver des bénévoles qui voulaient
magazine et avec des boules de coton
d'année mais c'est ça je blague on leur
a administré avec la gomme à mâcher
encore dans le bush polonais mais qui
auront le effectivement le trouver
qu'une odeur de menthe poivrée va faire
en sorte que tu va magasiner plus
longtemps pis à comparer une odeur de
cannelle ou une absence d'odeur
alors pour vous qui allez magasiner
taille dans les prochaines semaines et
menez vous d'électro gombo peut-être
prendre un psychiatre de bonbons quelque
part les notes france auriel on peut
dire c'est une façon de manipuler pide
dans certaines causes c'est vrai mais
dans certaines d'autres s'ajoutent
simplement à l'expérience globale que ce
soit au magasin que soient importés ou
d'autres moi ce que j'aime penser c'est
un outil qu'on peut tout utilisé dans
nos jours de tous les jours dans nos
vies de tous les jours
par exemple l'activité physique les
nutritionnistes qui disent alors ils
vont tout dire on devra marcher plus on
devrait bouger plus mais combien prend
chaque jour les escaliers l'autre jour
je serai dans un édifice pillet veine
files d'attentes pour les pros
l'ascenseur j'ai demandé à la réception
puis elle m'a dit je demander est-ce
qu'il y en ait sky ici elle a soupiré
puis elle me dit oui mais faut prendre
le couloir droit jusqu'au bout tu tourne
à droite du tourne-à-gauche france est
porteur qui se prend la 2e porte à
droite après alors ça c'est pas super
facile c'est pas évident on rentre dans
l'édifice qui on est encouragé de
prendre l'ascenseur puis l'autre côté
les escaliers sont les sons sont gris
sont profs sont pas super le fun de
passer du temps on veut qu'on veut faire
survivre avec un étage qui sait tout
mais s'il ya un moyen d'encourager le
monde utilisé
on peut mettre un tapis de couleur par
terre c'est beau ici dans une station de
métro
mais le problème c'est ce tapis de
couleurs nous mène aux escaliers
roulants
si le dessinateur voulait vraiment nous
encourager il y aurait continué ses
tapis là pour les escaliers alors en
huit ans les notes chance auriel on peut
penser à mettre plus de couleurs dans
les escaliers on peut passer à m dos
d'un ordre de menthe poivrée
pourquoi au lieu de taille passé du
premier au deuxième étage on passe du
deuxième au quatrième ou cinquième étage
même chose pour la musique la musique
une musique lente peu à dès qu'on monte
d'une cadence d'une bonne cadence qu'on
ne court pas dans les escaliers puis on
monte ça encore qu'on est encouragée de
continuer à utiliser les escaliers à
chaque fois alors moi modifie pour vous
c'est de penser autant dans votre vie
que vous pouvez utiliser des notes
chancelière est-ce que c'est pendant que
vous étudiez mettre un peu de menthe
poivrée
est ce que c'est de demander des
questions à votre place dans le poids de
demander est ce qu'on peut mettre des
signes pour mettre plus en évidence les
sky et il ya plein d'opportunités qu'on
peut utiliser puis l'autre chose que
vous je veux que vous rappeler c'est le
façon que les commerces utilisent ces
notes change rien pour nous manipuler
pourquoi qu'on prend conscience de
qu'est ce qu'ils font et comment qu'ils
font merci